French president Emanuel McCoy's due to
host a videoconference with his Russian
counterpart Vladimir Putin and the
security situation in Libya will be at
the top of the agenda the north african
nation is less than two thousand
kilometres away from continental europe
it's become a bloody battleground for a
number of players vying for power in the
oil-rich country one of them is Fayez
Sarraj who leads the UN installed
government in Tripoli on the other side
his military strongman Khalifa Haftar
a rebel general who now controls
two-thirds of the country including
Libya's oil fields so far his attempts
to take control of the capital have
failed I'm now joined by a Christian
khana he's a Middle East expert from the
Battlement foundation and joins me now
mr. honored how concerned should Europe
be about a resurgence in Islamist terror
and a migrant exodus from Libya thanks
for inviting me to the show Garrett we
should be concerned about the situation
the developments in Libya all the time
it's a country close to our neighborhood
and it is a failed state with rich
resources what you just said and and in
2014 and 2015 there were selves of the
Islamic state in Libya which have been
fought by different militias there are
still networks of of Islamic jihadist
fighters in the country Turkey has been
bringing some jihadists from northern
Syria for their interest and there are
linkages of Islamists between Libya and
Mali on the one on the other hand our
concern with refugees yes there is a
concern the situation of the hand of the
ten thousands of refugees and migrants
in the detention camps in Libya is in
bad shape United Nations and
international organization of migrants
need support but these migrants and
refugees know how dangerous the
situation Libya is and and they would
like to
to go through Libya well president
mcholland and also Vladimir Putin are
backing a general half tower while Italy
and Turkey are supporting the un-backed
government so just what are you
expecting from today's virtual summit
there we are now at a very critical
point as Turkey has been militarily
helping our to advance the Western
government to send quite in the middle
of the country as a frontline around
suit and jofre
and on the other side the general
huffner who is supported militarily and
politically by Russia and by the United
Arab Emirates and as well as Egypt so
they are internal to internal rifts with
the potential of escalation and external
interests France is officially with the
EU position to support the Western
government of the UN let Prime Minister
Suraj
but practically do do to Frances strong
strategic relations militarily and
financially with the United Arab
Emirates it has some sympathy for the
United Arab Emirates position on on
eastern Libya and it's there with Russia
the problem is my final idea on that is
jihad that the EU will have no influence
on what Turkey and Russia are deciding
on the future of Libya and this is what
is of great political concern for the EU
the cinemas from the Bertelsmann
foundation thank you very much for
joining us today
you